216 millions c'est le nombre de
personnes dans le monde qui pourrait
devenir des réfugiés climatiques d'ici à
2050 c'est en tout cas ce qu'estime la
banque mondiale l'institution vient de
publier la deuxième édition de son
rapport intitulé groundswell une
nouvelle version beaucoup plus
pessimiste que la précédente concernant
les déplacements de population liés au
changement climatique
en 2018 le rapport estimait que 143
millions de personnes pourraient être
amenés à se déplacer d'ici à 2050 avec
216 millions aujourd'hui c'est désormais
1,5 fois plus ce rapport c'est donc je
cite un appel opportun à une action
urgente les effets du changement
climatique sont de plus en plus visible
nous venons de vivre la décennie la plus
chaude jamais enregistrée et nous
assistons à des phénomènes
météorologiques extrêmes dans le monde
le climat de la terre connaissant des
changements dans chaque région et dans
l'ensemble du système climatique parmi
les régions concernées par ces futurs
déplacements de population l'afrique et
l'asie l'afrique subsaharienne mais
aussi l'afrique du nord où les
perturbations liées à la disponibilité
de l'eau constitue l'un des principaux
moteurs des déplacements de population
en asie du sud selon les modélisations
le bangladesh se révèle particulièrement
concernée avec 13,3 millions de
potentiels futurs déplacés climatiques
en cause la fragilité du pays face à la
montée des eaux la banque mondiale
appelle donc les pays du globe à agir et
ce dès aujourd'hui il est crucial d'agir
maintenant sur le triple plan du climat
du développement et des migrations afin
d'assurer la réalisation des objectifs
de développement durable au cours des
dix prochaines années et parvenir à la
prospérité partagée d'ici au milieu du
siècle présent et au delà ces prévisions
ne sont pas figées pour la banque
mondiale il est encore possible de
réduire le nombre de réfugiés
climatiques à venir notamment si les
pays s'engagent vers des modes de vie
plus respectueux de l'environnement
les migrations climatiques pourraient
être réduites de 80 % ce qui représente
tout de même 44 millions de personnes
d'ici à 2050